directes depuis londres avec martin mc
cauley analyste politique
[Musique]
bonjour martin mc cauley merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
commission européenne qui lance une
procédure d'infraction contre le royaume
uni concrètement ça veut dire quoi que
risque le royaume uni mais est il
valable jusqu'à ce qu'en amont de la fin
décembre lorsque le royaume espère de
tomber d'accord sur un acte juridique il
permettra de quitter l'union européenne
avec une forme d'accord cela devient
plus difficile parce que londres suit
son propre intérêt et essaye de défendre
ses intérêts l'union européenne a un
avis différent
disons qu'il s'agit d'une infraction
d'une violation du droit européen et
elle nous devons défendre notre point de
vue continuons à discuter sur le sujet
parce que cela rend les choses plus
difficiles pour les deux parties en
prévision de fin décembre du départ du
[Musique]
royaume-uni aimerait avoir
ce jour-là un accord de départ mais
l'association est maintenant décoction a
compliqué et le temps va commencer à
manquer cependant j'espère que l'on va
trouver un compromis que le royaume uni
et jeux européens réussiront à trouver
un accord mais avec cette procédure est
ce que la discussion commerciale entre
les deux parties est impactée beaucoup
de gars j'ai certainement car les
discussions commerciales ne se passe pas
très bien
l'accord négocié avec l'union européenne
est vu par l'industrie britannique comme
un mauvais accord car cela signifiera
beaucoup de droits de douane chose on
estime certaines personnes estiment
qu'il faudrait 50 mille employés des
douanes supplémentaires pour traiter la
paperasse bloque les négociations vont
continuer on l'espère entre espère que
l'union européenne accepte que les lois
et les principes britanniques sont
équivalents au principe européen mais
c'est une nouvelle protestation par
l'union européenne qui dit que le
royaume lui enfreint la loi européenne
avant la situation en cela beaucoup plus
difficile ne pouvons qu'espérer que les
deux parties vont se rassembler et
trouver une solution avant le 31
décembre alors une procédure lancée au
moment même où des négociations se
tiennent on en parlait quel message vous
lancer l'union européenne à travers
cette procédure selon vous les
européennes veut montrer qu'elle a une
position très solide qu'elle est plus
forte dans ce dans ces négociations que
le royaume uni et qu'elle ne veut pas
faire de concessions l'union européenne
a des lois qu'elle souhaite défendre et
le royaume uni a une vision différente
de ces lois a une attitude différente
le système légal système juridique
britannique est un système de recherche
de solutions les lois changent
régulièrement
la loi européenne est beaucoup plus
strictes
c'est une loi écrite qui remonte au code
napoléon c'est un système
j'aurais dit que différents ce n'est pas
un comme l'eau comme on peut le trouver
par exemple en angleterre
donc c'est là que repose la difficulté
parce que les avocats eux-mêmes les
juristes sont deux cultures différentes
et il va donc falloir beaucoup de
discussions et l'union européenne doit
donner un peu de mou et comprendre que
le royaume uni effectivement en position
difficile et le royaume uni doit
accepter que l'union européenne a ses
propres lois qui doivent être respectées
il faut trouver un compromis et de la
part des deux parties pour conclure en
quelques mots ou est-ce qu'on peut
encore croire que les deux parties
parviendront à un accord où finalement
le no deal se profile
beaucoup de britanniques
effectivement il y aura un audit le 31
décembre
les industries britanniques notamment la
ville de londres
seul un accord et ils font pression
auprès du gouvernement pour un accord
m même si c'est un mauvais accord pour
le royaume uni il faut un accord car
sans accord la situation serait bien
pire il y aurait beaucoup de confusion
le 1er janvier 2021
merci beaucoup martin mc cauley pour
votre analyse rappelle que vous êtes
analyste politique